I hope you've got a fantastic day and in
this video it's where it gets very very
exciting because this is the video where
I'm going to explain exactly how you can
buy properties without using any of your
own money and I'm doing this all the
time and so many of my students I do
talk about this in my book by low rent
high and again if you haven't read this
I really recommend it if you have read
it don't forget please do go to Amazon
current UK and leave me a lovely review
and that would be very very kind of you
as well
so so far video one was about what is
financial freedom and getting us in the
right mindset of property investing and
also busting the 7 myths that society
has led us to believe to be true video 2
was then about okay we wanna buy
properties we're excited when's the best
time to buy and what do we buy what are
the gold wine areas what are the areas
we should stay away from and what's
gonna happen in the next few years with
the property economy and this video is
about how to buy properties with no
money
so there are effectively four ways that
you can make serious money through
property starting with nothing and
effectively you can start out with zero
and if you take on board any of these
hallways you go and absolutely smash it
now the one that we're going to be
looking at today doesn't stop at a Zen e
or no it starts with an O this is one of
my favorite ways to make money and buy
my property and that is options namely
lease option agreements lease options
when I started buying property in 2008
2009 upon a time what you used to be
able to do everyone at the time with
buying properties below market value and
then they were refinancing the property
is the same day and pulling all of them
I thought boom this sounds great so what
just as I got on board guess what
happened I'll tell you exactly what
happened
this the rules changed but again and
then what I said the people that make up
the rules make money in property so if
the rules change don't get bummed out
don't get worried what what happened was
effectively you could no longer buy and
we financed the same day so today you
have to wait six months which has a lot
of complications they made my strategy
much more difficult and everyone say the
days of buying with no money you have
over however 2009 I went on a training
program where they taught you how to buy
property with no money using lease
option agreement
now the cool thing is this I'll give you
the good news and the bad news the bad
news is when I went on the training
program although I had a lot fun and
they were jumping up and down on the
tables shouting about lose option
agreements are fantastic and all this I
can actually learn anything about lease
option agreement
I don't really fun time I didn't learn
anything about lease option agreements
don't feel too bad for me though because
they had the advanced program you've
been on these programs before were they
and then was spending a lot of money and
at the end of it I did now I do you
talking agreements but again it was kind
of theory and through trial and error
blood sweat and tears and making a lot
of mistakes along the way I figured out
how to do lease option agreements and
smoothly and effectively buy properties
with no money on option agreements not
many people are doing this I mean a lot
of investors they know about this but
they're not doing it in fact me and my
students are the only people that I've
met that are actively doing this people
just know about it and talk about it so
I'm gonna condense what I know about
these option agreements into the next
sort of horrible ten minutes and you
will know probably more than I did
after going on my initial three day
course that's the good news
so let me give you an example I'll give
you an example of a lease option
agreement I did five years ago so it's
two bedrooms his stories
so you really understand this so there's
a guy called Steve and he buys a house
for ninety five thousand pounds true
story by the way this house is in Warsaw
box which true story it has four ninety
five thousand pounds and he puts down a
small deposit of about fourteen thousand
pounds so his mortgage outstanding he's
eighty one thousand that since mortgage
this is his purchase price and the
mortgage payments are a hundred and
forty five pounds per month for the
mortgage payments so that's the set up
now Steve pauses it but he doesn't live
in it he rents it out to his son always
lovely his son pays him quite a
conservative a rent of four hundred and
fifty pounds per month and he's making a
little bit of profit but really he
bought it with what his feelings he
bought it free son today with some a
favor he's making a few new pounds a
little profit but he wants his son to
one day buy the house often he wants it
to be sons home importantly these
feelings now what happens at this point
is Steve moves away to Derbyshire with
his wife to retire so they're now often
dog share far away from the house but
it's okay because even though they're
very brisk of those people lessons in
the house looking after it problem
there's some moves out and now the house
is empty
and therefore fifty Ren becomes nothing
and they're paying one hundred and forty
five thousand every single month the
house is empty
and they don't want to be landlords they
don't wanna reach out to anybody else
and they are thinking oh my gosh
what do we do so they do the only thing
that they can do you can try and
remember these figures that'll be great
because we're going to look months now
but eighty one thousand is the mortgage
outstanding that's the important one to
remember so they think oh my goodness
what are we going to do and then you saw
that the only thing
can do they live so far away and the
house is empty is is to set up sell the
property so they go to an estate agent
in the estate agent sells I think you
bought it for nine to five thousand but
you know what the economy and different
things it's not going to be simple to
get your money back so what we would
suggest is that you put it on for
nineteen thousand so you put it on for
nine thousand and in six weeks they have
three viewings two of them cancelled and
one of them came in off at seventy-five
thousand pounds not good news
so now Steve is pulling his hair out
selling it's empty at the moment there
could be squatters that move in and they
could trash the place I don't know what
about it
so Steve got in touch with me and I'll
also tell you about how to find these
types of deals in the next video okay so
so Steve get in touch it with me and he
said Samuel could you please buy the
house off me for ninety thousand pounds
I think my five for it but I'll let you
have it for ninety now from my point of
view if I buy it from ninety and rent it
out for 450 now it will probably in
fairness get more than that but I'm not
going to get more than 550 rents so if I
buy it for 1920 to 550 back to the last
video what to buy is that gonna be a
good investment for me and the answer is
no because the my return is probably
going to be maybe around 15% you know
it's not very good night brand 550 rare
and that's max you know the returns not
great okay but it's not fantastic so is
it no I couldn't do that so all I said
to Steve I can't 490 but I could buy it
for eighty thousand pounds now from
Steve's point of view not only is that
considerably less than he paid for it
but it's got a bit of a problem and the
problem is that he's mortgage
outstanding if you remember was 81 which
means that Steve is actually gonna
Lily's actually not only is he gonna
sell it and lose all his deposit money
he's gonna lose almost deposit lose all
his money means he's going to have to
pay a thousand pounds to his mortgage
company because to make up the
difference that makes sense so that's
not really very feasible so he says look
if you give me 85 that'll cover all my
costs and I'm pretty much just break
even so I think it's ok great a really
good asset so oh it's sticky point now
most people would leave the offer on the
table would walk away and hope that one
day Steve comes back to them and says
yes in the meantime you'd have probably
sold it with the estate agent or you
know the deal will fall through they'll
walk away however I didn't walk away
I made Steve a very interesting proposal
and that is not a lease option agreement
you know people that would offer a lease
option agreement at this point would
never get it so my first buffer is 80
cash that's my first offer and Steve
says no so what you need to do at this
point is you need to begin to exhaust
the options so okay Steve or how about
why don't you keep on with the estate
agents do that and talk to him about
their idea of just keeping it on and if
he goes yeah I can do that then great
walk away if he says keep on with the
estate agent but the nuts they hold all
their crazies and on forever and he
doesn't want to do that then you
offering the not lease option agreement
then pretend that Steve's your brother
and you're giving him you're giving your
best advice to a best friend I said
Steve this is where you should do this
is the best thing that you should do it
rent out I can connect you of a local
that major in the area it's a good
property I reckon you'll get 550 for it
now if Steve says yeah I'll rent it out
then guess what you've helped too
that's okay because again a big a big
misconception with property investors is
that you need to make money by getting
good deals no you make money by adding
value to people and by being a problem
solver so I tend to rent out now this
point Steve was running the face saying
look so I don't want to end out I've
already told you I don't want to be
alone Lord and you know what this is
very risk-averse
so when you've exhausted always possible
options he won't accept two below market
value doesn't want to keep all of an
estate engine he doesn't want to rent
out be a landlord himself then you want
from the lease option agreement they
don't call it a lease option agreement
you effectively just say something like
this okay Steve so you don't want to do
these things I may be able to offer you
something like this I could give you a
ninety five thousand however you
wouldn't get paid for another five years
what are you crazy
hot weather now I would take over your
mortgage payments take over complete
responsibility the property and it would
be effectively like it was mind you been
to walk away from it and then in five
years time to read $95,000 now what's he
thinking he's thinking well I'll get a
lot more money down the line if it
serves dad won't like anything yeah
that's perfect
however everything what time you always
say no and there's a few magic words you
can say now I'm running out of time I
won't have only got about two minutes
left but there's a few magic words that
you say which will getting yes every
single time and again if you call them
to my property investors crash course
what we're going through these ed-e are
and we're going through this in a lot
more detail so if you've not been on the
crash course I would really recommend
going on but there's a few magic words
you can say when he says yes he did say
yes five years ago he's really happy
he had the property you know take it
taken off him straight away and he
didn't have to pay his mortgage company
didn't have to do any more viewings he
didn't have to deal with any tenants me
I took over his mortgage uh one point
five
mortgage rented out the same day rented
out the same day I got the keys for 5/5
day which means that I'm making a profit
of 400 pound a gross profit of 400
pounds per month not bad but no money
down whatsoever in the last five years
the property has gone up by forty five
thousand pounds so I've made four
hundred pounds a month and I've made
forty five thousand pounds in capital
appreciation and I invested nothing
because it was all done on a lease
option agreement now I appreciate that
is a short summary version but you know
what this without five years ago I did a
deal last week just like this up north
so this is a fantastic strategy if you
want a little bit more about these
options agreements understand how it
works and the paperwork and different
stuff like that I'd recommend this video
right here and have a fantastic evening
the next video is going to be on how to
find these types of deals how to find
deals how to source eight amounts how to
saw cigarettes have to source options so
watch out for that it becoming in your
inbox very very soon god bless and hope
to see you at the crash course
[Music]